السلام عليكم
كم واحد فيكم
عنده معينه
بتحبها وتذكروا الاغنيه الموقف معين او
بشخص معين او بنخله معينه
اغلبنا اعتقد الجميع
الفكره كلها
ان الموسيقى بشكل عام
لما انا كنت ببحث في الموضوع
انه في جزء من اجزاء المخ
مضبوطه كثيرا يعني عندكم ذاكره خاصه في
الموسيقى ففي بعض الاشياء
عندنا الموسيقى قد تتذكرون بطريقه اكبر
وهذه الذاكره
مضبوطه جدا
في اللغه
والكلمات
وتعبير بعض المواطن
وبعدين في النهايه اسمعكم اياها مره ثانيه
وبعدين بقول لكم
صحصح مع بعض
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
علينا مطلوب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يريدون الاجابه
[تصفيق]
طبعا
هذه بسيطه عن عامه
هذه الاغنيه الفت اماني انا شفت صاحب
طبعا بتروح للشواطئ
الطبيعه تعمل فيها
المسار الجبلي بشكل عام
مكان جميل مبنيه على
مشاكل وتحديات بيديه كبيره
لكن بامانه
انا ما اعرف
وصف المعلومه ما عرفت كيف اتكلم عن
الموضوع هذا الانسان بطبيعته
فكانت الموسيقى كانت موسيقى مخرج
التعبير واللي فهمته انا بعدين
انه الموسيقى قد تعبر عن بعض الاشياء
الكلام يعجز الكلام
فاضطريت يتوجه الى الموسيقى
فلما كتبتها طبعا تواصل اجتماعي موجود
الانستجرام انا خليتها على الانستجرام
لكن وضعتها على الانستغرام
وبدايه استخدم فيديوهات
اطفال حملات تنظيف
مطلوب من العتاله علينا
هذا الشيء الجميل لانه
الناس
[موسيقى]
وتفكرت في الموضوع ايش
الموضوع هذا فلما دخلت
وجدت انه هذا حتى حتى الناس اللي مرات
ضربات في الدماغ والعقل او الناس
بشكل عام
ينقل الموسيقى للتعبير عن اشياء قديمه
النفس
اذا كان في كلمات معينه
اتذكر هذه تشتغل بطريقه معينه
عظيمه
من الجانب الاخر السلوكي وجدنا انه
الموسيقى يشجع
فانا فهمت من هذا الباب انه في السلوك
السلبي
الانسان ما يحتاج لاي ساهل جدا الواحد
يعمل
سهل جدا للانسان
وما يفكر
لكن
عندما يكون
العمل التشريع
والدافع عن وجود حكم انه العمل الايجابي
جهد
دائما بالعمل الايجابي
لمن الواحد يخرج
الارض حتى زباله جميع معين فهذه
الغمامه هتخليها معها
هذا ايضا جهد فالانسان يحافظ الايجابي
يحتاجه
فهنا كانس
يتنكر كان عندنا ضعف في اليد
ولو احنا لو لقينا ايضا الى الدين
الدين ما كسرت لكن في التعليم التنوع
في التعليم وخاصه الذاكره الموسيقيه
تساعد الانسان في ادراك المعلومه لما هو
ما بعد المعدوم
في معلومات عنها المصطلحات لكن لا تترس
لان احنا فقط عرفناها واحد زائد واحد
اتنين لكن لم تشعر به واحد زائد واحد
يساوي اثنين كيف يعني افضل مثال اوضع اللي
هو
اذا الانسان عمره ما خلى عن
عمره ما يعلم
عمره ما تكون النار عاديه عديده بالنسبه
يقول هذه
معرفه عن فتاثر على الفعل عنكم انسان لم
يعرف
عمره ما جرى بما حرم
بس لو الانسان يبقى مسكت النار
واحترقت بيعمل
ضد الفعل
تبني كثيرا على مدى وعي الانسان في مفاه
المعلومه اللي حصلتها
فهذه لما انا عندي تجمعت معي المعلومات
هذه
عن طريق
الى بريد الاكبر وافضل
تطبيق بعدين وشجع الناس
وهنا اصبح
الفن اليه جميله الت
هامي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عندما الواحد
عمل معين
تو والمحتوى الصوتي هذا من زمان
كان دائما
القصص
الشعر
والحين
التواصل الاجتماعي
هذه محتويات قويه جدا وانا دائما المحتوى
الصوتي اقوى من المحكمه الصور
بحكم اذا وضع حاله وضع الداعي
فترسخ المعلومه
هذا الشيء احنا نموت
فكل المقويات الصوتيه عاده ترسخ بطريقه
[موسيقى]
في هذا الفيديو
لا تتكلم اللغه العربيه
غير باللغه العربيه يريد اللغه العربيه
هذه حتى انهم يضموا العمل
اتهم
كل الاع
مال
يعني تقريبا مع صوت شخص الى 70 شخص
ومدينه الحمام وبكل قوه بطريقه ايجابيه
الانسان ان يشوف اكثر من شخص
يه او في الموسيقى معينه او صوره معينه
الجميع يقدر يتفاعل بطريقه جميله هذا
التاثير هل التاثير هو عالم اللي يوصل
للمساله
طريقه
فانا
الخميسي الشعوب
[موسيقى]
مطلوب علينا
مع بعض
[موسيقى]
الارض شفت
وا هذا شعوركم الخجل هذا الشعور بالضبط هل
[موسيقى]
الشعور
بكل صوت
كل صوت منكم يكون رساله
وكل ما واحد منكم فيكم غنى
[موسيقى]
بيحاول
اعلمك الشخصي بعدين
بعدين شجره الناس
خمسين من الناس
الايجابي
والعمل الايجابي
العمل
مثل مثلا
الفكر او السلوك
بس الفرق
بعدين خمسين خمس بعدين انا اطمح
الله
يخليكم ساعدوني اوصل
لانه في
داك
الذاكره هي
اللي انا اعتبر
في منتج
ات كلمات تكون طويله بعض الشيء
اللحم ايجابي وشفت العمل الايجابي كله من
الاجابه وانتم كلكم
لكن كيف الشغل كيف العب مع الناس انهم
يعملوا سلوك ايجابي
مره اخرى صح وتقبل الناس مختلف
الخيام مختلف
لكن
لما الواحد يؤمن بالعمل الايجابي ويبعد
عمل الايجابي بالتواجد في السلوك الصح
ويجعل من الجميع هنا قوه الموسيقى وقوه
الفرد فيها قوه اجماع الناس كطاقه واحده
نظرا الى الثمره الحقيقيه له الا وهي
من التقاط الانسانيه التواصل بالعمل
[تصفيق]